pousser un seau une chute et Barbâtre
dans l'année qu'elle s'est traînée sur
quelques mètres mon dieu c'est affreux
le véhicule est au nom de ma gymore
Daddy magimont
assassinant l'espace d'une semaine et
c'est bizarre ça
je suis mort
[Musique]
tout de suite ouais je suis chez moi ici
je l'ai entendu hurler le mot saleté
très clairement oh tu es mon ami jade
quelque chose ma femme menace d'aller à
la police ce que j'attends de toi c'est
que tu lui fasses peur pour qu'elle
change d'avis
[Musique]
EUR
attendez on a deux magimal dans le
système je me demande comment ça peut
arriver
est là pour noyer la piste si tu te
débrouilles pour supprimer la deuxième
main ça donnera l'impression que Mama
guide pétait une simple erreur comme si
c'était un accident et je serai tiré
d'affaires
j'avais clairement spécifié de lui faire
peur pas de la faire cramer je sais pas
qui a fait ça mais on a affaire un
virtuel et de loin comme ça dis avait
l'air de se faire un peu bousculer
cette cinglée et c'est de me faire
porter le chapeau c'est totalement
stupide cette fille vient me balancer le
mari de ma Lili une assurance vie
tout ça sur un plateau d'argent
[Musique]